I've been running a faceless YouTube
channel for over two years getting
millions of views until I realized that
I've been doing it all wrong there's a
way to achieve these results in just a
few months let me explain
so the channel I'm talking about is
called Zia where I make short and long
form videos about Marvel movies in this
video I'll focus on the short form
content how you can get similar views as
quickly as possible and show you the
exact method I use to make them go viral
thank you
treat your channel as a brand decide
what fonts and colors you'll use and
keep them consistent throughout your
channel to get started you're going to
need a logo and a banner you can make
them in any photo editor you want or if
you're not a good designer you can make
one using mid Journey like I do
if you're posting randomly without
choosing a clear topic sorry but you
can't succeed on this platform so pick a
niche you want make sure there's people
out there who want to watch content from
that Niche you can ask chatgpt to give
you a list of the most popular niches on
YouTube or go to Wikipedia search for
list of hobbies and pick one that you're
interested in then jump straight into
step three
you need to analyze other big channels
in your Niche and see which type of
content is doing well recently I did the
same when I started out my channel and
saw facts about movies doing pretty well
in my Niche you probably saw at least
one video like this did you know an
Avengers end game do you know that in
spider did you know your love and
thunder so I found a bunch of
interesting facts and explained them as
simply as I could in my videos one thing
I strongly recommend is don't overthink
it spend as little time as you can on
making each video especially when you're
first starting out you're going to have
a lot of time to improve your content
but when you're in the beginning just
publish your first video as soon as you
can get comfortable making that style of
content then choose one side of the
video to improve next time for example
focus on making better transitions in
the next five videos then better
subtitles better coloring better sound
effects and so on it will definitely
increase your video quality instead of
trying to make everything perfect back
to the channel after publishing
consistently for about three weeks I
made my first viral video
foreign
10 shorts or so you need to go back and
analyze data see which videos are doing
well and which does this step may be a
bit boring for some of you but it's
definitely the most crucial one so don't
skip that and the only important metrics
you should check for YouTube shorts are
view count retention and swipe rate but
more importantly just re-watch your most
viewed videos and try to understand what
makes them different from the rest write
them down in a viral recipe list and you
can either try to tick as many boxes as
you can in your next shorts or choose a
few for each video and Implement them
one by one I made that list for my viral
short and saw the subtitles were shorter
the scene was changing faster and I made
a joke at the end that wasn't funny
anyways I use this list for my next
videos and I got two more viral shorts
at the end of that month so in December
2022 I finally got monetized
[Music]
what worked in the past May no longer
work today after replicating the same
formula for the next month I realize the
formula is not working anymore even
though it was monetized the Channel's ad
Revenue was less than twenty dollars a
month obviously things weren't looking
good even though I used the same
techniques the views were getting lower
in each video if you came across that
hitch on your channel too it's the sign
showing the golden formula is broken or
needs a revision you need to repeat step
three and four and add new points to
your viral recipe list and when I did it
again this time I saw better performing
videos had a sound effect in the
beginning like this some type of graphic
that takes attention and most of them
didn't have a voiceover they were just
cool edits of recent movies even though
I was a bit suspicious since it was
easier to make this type of content I
made more of them and they did really
well the channel was getting more and
more traction every day the ad Revenue
went from 20 to over one hundred fifty
dollars that month everything was great
I was sure it would easily turn into
thousands of dollars in a few months
until one day I got an email from
YouTube
thank you
it said some of your videos have been
taken down due to a copyright notice we
had to take down the following three
videos from YouTube so basically my
three edits about the movie spider-verse
has been taken down by Sony and my
channel got a copyright strike but
that's not the worst part a few hours
after that my channel got demonetized
because of reused content it turns out
my edits weren't edited enough to meet
the fair use it was just the worst thing
that could ever happen after the channel
was starting to take off
but that didn't stop me from posting I
now went back to adding voiceovers to my
videos repeated step three and four
again to make my formula even better and
will reapply the YouTube Partner program
in a few weeks
so if there's one principle you need to
use on your channel after this video
it's determination no matter how
challenging it is just learn from each
experience and try to improve find
Solutions and don't lose your motivation
[Music]
thank you